Hi guys,
You are on the English Online
Business English series.
Now, I know some of us have seen some
massive changes to our working environments
over the past two years, and that’s why
today we are talking about agile work.
Now, there is a common misconception
that agility is about speed.
Agile work is not only about working
quickly but also about flexibility and
more importantly about efficiency.
Today, we are looking at having an
agile working rhythm.
That is not:
Our American clients have
pushed back that meeting,
we’re going to have it at 6pm tonight if that’s
okay with you? Sorry, I’m working from 9 till 5,
I won’t be in the office at 6 today.
But looks something a little bit
more like this.
Our American clients have
pushed back that meeting,
we’re going to have it at 6pm
tonight if that’s okay with you?
Yeah, that’s no problem, I’ll come in an hour
later tomorrow, or I might take an extra hour
at lunch and go to that bookshop.
But yeah, tonight at 6 is fine.
There has been a shift away from that typical 9
to 5, Monday to Friday where five days a week,
8 hours a day, being on time and making sure that
you looked busy is what made you a model employee.
But now, we deal with emails and phone calls, from
our personal devices. Communicate with clients or
colleagues outside of those normal working hours.
So, what should we do?
We need to be working smarter, not just harder.
Today at 6? Should be no problem.
Don’t burn yourself out.
Let’s stop for a quick break
there guys, I want to break
down the language.
Today we’re looking at phrasal verbs, also knownas multi-word verbs.
This is when you have a verband you add
a particle or two particles in some
cases and this changes the meaning of the verb.
Today we looked at the verb 'to burn',
added the preposition 'out', 'to burn out'.
This means to overwork yourself
and become exhausted. Don't burn yourself out!
So what is important from
today’s video guys?
It’s really crucial that we begin to find
and create a good work life balance.
I hope you enjoyed our short video today.
If you’re interested in following along with
the rest of our series then please subscribe to
our channel by clicking on the button below.
If you haven’t already seen
some of the other great content
on things like conflict management or interview
tips, then you can click on the link you see here,
and that will take you straight to it.
Thanks for watching guys,
I will see you next time.